(music)
This place seems to be full of traps this game has taught me to be wary of my surroundings
Was this a dark narrow passageway with no room to roll away better proceed carefully?
Where's the trap aha a pressure plate, but where what would it trigger ah?
There! arrows of course hMM
Yes, it's a good thing. I was paying attention every trap in this game can be avoided oh
Yolo, [oh], what the fuck artificial difficulty trial and error gameplay unavoidable death the game is too hard
You'll notice I used the phrase artificial difficulty at the end there and some of you might be wondering what that is
Artificial difficulty is a term that became very popular around the time dark souls was released for PC
It refers to a state of difficulty where failure is unavoidable for one reason or another
for example
Maybe you were about to die an unavoidable death because it was literally impossible to tell what was about to kill you
Perhaps the camera glitched out, and you can blame the game code for your death
Or maybe a boss has no apparent weakness and requires trial and error to take down
It's rare that a game has artificial difficulty in a pure form
Because most circumstances that lead to failure are completely avoidable
Games like Dark souls are unique in that they require to the player to be in a constant state of skill and awareness to stop
Them being punished make one mistake because you missed an environmental clue
Or opportunity and you may find that you died or that you had your character disadvantaged in some way and in my opinion
This is the best kind of difficulty
It's the kind where you are rewarded for paying attention or exploring and dark souls does this exceptionally well for [example]
There's bloodstains on this platform [leading] up to the spikes on the roof
There's corpses bloodstains and child's stone on this bridge that gets burned by a dragon
There's a key that unlocks a shortcut further past this boss room
And there's a ladder here which allows you to do a plunging attack. Which you should have learnt in the tutorial
This is a game where [you] learn which way to go because an area is too hard
Rather than have a huge compass on your screen at all times like most modern games in
The Edge article about Dark Souls 2 should [goo] your talks of enhancing these clues and rewards
And that's one of the things I'm most excited for
artificial difficulty states that you shouldn't have to learn through trial and error I
Personally like trial and error gameplay learning from your mistakes is [what] makes the better player however?
I understand why many people complain about trial and error gameplay some fights like the bed of Chaos or Capra Demon
Almost require you to fail before you can try [again] with the capra
Demon you are thrust into an intense fight where it's almost impossible to take in your surroundings before you can make a plan
It would have been better in my opinion if you could observe the room beforehand with the bed of Chaos
We have a boss fight that was poorly thought out because you are likely to die no matter. How many times you've done the fight
Additionally when you open a mimic chest you were going to die the first time you do so with no warning
Unless you read the art book of course
These are examples of difficulty that could have been done better since skill plays less of a part in these than trial and error does
So let me know what you think for the most part?
I think dark souls does difficulty really well, and I don't want to see this style change in the next [souls] game. We receive
Dark souls is set apart from most modern games not because it is incredibly difficult, but because it handles difficulty really damn well